netanyahu ha hablado de Buscar diálogo
pero culpa a los que llama extremistas
de intentar destruir al país qué podemos
deducir de la situación política de
netanyahu y su gobierno a partir de
estas palabras y del retraso del
proyecto
Hola Rodrigo y Hola a todos los oyentes
de France 24 y a los que nos ven por
televisión pues definitivamente
la necesidad de suspender la Reforma es
algo que se ha venido discutiendo desde
varios frentes Incluso como bien decían
en el titular galán verdad que fue el
ministro de defensa en algún momento
también se opuso a la reforma y pidió
que se aplazara ante lo cual incluso
netaniao llamó a destituirlo de su cargo
y esto ha llevado a una serie de gente
que se ha ido sumando a las protestas en
contra de netania desde la reforma y lo
que lo ha obligado a que el día de hoy
tomaran la decisión finalmente de
aplazar la segunda y tercera lectura de
las leyes de reforma que se estaban
planteando inicialmente y también tratar
de empezar un diálogo una negociación
con líderes de la oposición
principalmente Benny gangs Verdad que es
el el líder del partido unidad nacional
y una de las figuras más emblemáticas en
estos momentos
y podríamos llegar a ver La retirada de
la Reforma o el Primer Ministro se juega
demasiado por sus casos de presunta
corrupción
Por el momento no se ve que se vayan a
sacar de hecho más bien por el contrario
esto es un aplazamiento para tratar de
retomar las discusiones después de la
pausa que va a haber la próxima semana
con motivo de la celebración de pesas y
posteriormente se va a volver a discutir
con los diferentes frentes pensemos que
una parte de lo que sostiene la
coalición de netanyahu son las figuras
de motrice y bennet verdad y su
coalición de gobierno es la que se ha
mantenido hasta el momento con una
negociación a través de la oposición y
principalmente con Benny gangs puede ser
que si eventualmente se diese algunos
cambios bastante pues profundos en la en
la medida finalmente algunas de estas
dos figuras decida salirse junto con
otros miembros del parlamento sí Cabe
señalar que entre las facciones de
derecha que apoyaban en inicialmente
incluso dos partidos como son el
tradicional partido chats y el partido
yajadura
tomaron la decisión también de pedirle a
nitaniau que aplazara o que detuviera un
poco todas las medidas relacionadas con
la con la reforma y yendo al movimiento
en las calles quienes forman el grueso
de las protestas y hasta Dónde podrían
llegar si nos echa tras la medida siendo
conciso podríamos ver caer al gobierno
de netanyahu
eventualmente esa podría ser una
posibilidad en estos momentos no es algo
que se vislumbre porque sigue teniendo
una coalición que por débil que parezca
sigue manteniéndose estable inmutable en
cuanto a sus posiciones pero cada vez se
van sumando más figuras no solamente de
izquierda o no solamente gente de grupos
sociales como sindicatos y demás sino
incluso figuras de derecha y figuras
públicas de la cultura y de otras de
otros medios en los cuales están
llamando a que se eche para atrás en
cuanto a la reforma y que netaneado
replantee poder hacer cambios hay que
quizás mencionar acá de que si hay
figuras que mencionan que es importante
la reforma judicial pero no esta reforma
tal cual está porque incluso toca
medidas relacionadas con la elección de
jueces y otros aspectos relacionados por
su lo que tiene que ver con normas
generales básicas recordemos que Israel
no cuenta con una constitución como tal
Y esto lleva que se dicten leyes que
tienen digamos una naturaleza casi
constitucional